Jordan good morning thanks for joining
us where do you weigh in on this is Ben
Simmons a rookie Oh Dan absolutely not
how for me technically as diving the
missile said Dan that yes
he's mean fits that bill but it's hard
for me to look at this and say he is he
is a legitimate rookie considering he
redshirted he had a year of eating right
getting on this person plan you know
going through an NBA season and seeing
it from that perspective so I think I
think he will win Rookie of the Year but
I don't know if you could really sit
back and say he is a legitimate rookie
man but he didn't play he was he was on
a roster but technically yeah he didn't
play he's been so good it's hard to take
away it's 12 triple doubles which is you
know a record in itself and the way he
sees the floor and thinks the game you
guys were talking about shooting it he
hasn't made a three all year most of
those 13 or 14 attempts or whatever they
were were just he's at the end of
quarter but his ability to think the
game is so inclusive that it's hard to
imagine he he's not going to just
continually improve because once he
starts to spread the floor and create
that dynamic of it that can at least hit
a 15 footer come off a ball screen hit
an 18-footer I mean everything's going
to open up the legitimacy of the 76ers
to win the East now is what I think it's
a lot higher than people want to get
them credit for they may descend at a
better level than they're getting credit
for and I think that's Brett Brown who
has constantly created this culture over
the last couple of years here they're
very young dandy it might be a year or
two away but he talked about him being
if he's healthy and even 90% he's to me
the best big men in the Eastern
Conference and I think his ability to
spread the floor as he just said and
pass and they have so many weapons with
Covington and Redick they've done a
really good job of getting this process
to go faster for a very young team the
most important game tonight the final
night of the regular season aside from
Denver
in Minnesota because that's the play in
game but the most important game that
fans should be aware of is what well
they're a Minnesota is I mean what are
you saying just putting that aside yeah
it's so obvious yeah ah that's a good
one then I haven't even looked at the
schedule of that game it's early it's
early in Los Angeles for you but I got
the Knicks in the Cavs Raptors heat
Wizards magic bucks Sixers Nuggets
Timberwolves Spurs pelicans Grizzlies
Thunder I'll go bucks Sixers because
there is a point somewhere during this
season with Milwaukee I thought they
would really figure it out whether that
was posted through cable show Prunty but
what their what they struggle with is
they have a complete the Bucks lack of
continuity where you watch them play and
something's missing
whether it's you know the ability to
play together for guys to fully trust
the Yanis is always going to make the
right decision I don't know if it's a
jealousy thing I talked to a coach
throughout the league throughout the
season that said he thought there was
some jealousy
even though guys really like be honest
they felt like well why can't this be my
team at least a little bit of the time
and so they struggled with that and I
think if you watch tonight you'll start
to see going into playoffs maybe there
is a little momentum for them because
they are to me one of the most dangerous
low seats and regardless regardless of
the conference's because II honest is
that good and they had the ability to
beat anybody I mean good night he's
Jordan Schultz yahoo sports insider
covering the NBA and the NFL among other
things you were speaking to Dwyane Wade
recently and one of the topics that came
up was free agency and it felt like
Dwyane Wade thinks Paul George is going
to the Lakers but the surprise of the
conversation I thought was Kawhi Leonard
to the Celtics yeah that was really
surprising and I think his thought
process was probably like bars Dan which
is something is really wrong there they
be it's so toxic and severed there
between front-office and co I'll enter
that it might really be at the point of
no return and he said something that
struck me which was he's essentially
heard Kawhi Leonard say two words like
for a great superstar caliber player
who's entering his prime dan have you do
you recall a time where a the
relationship with the front office was
this bad and be where nobody really
knows what the guys thinking like he
wouldn't they have behoove him to come
out Kawhi Leonard and say everything's
okay and or at least something so we we
know where he's at but he hasn't done
that and I think that's been the biggest
probably the biggest surprise for even
poor guy like Dwayne Wade well we also
look at Kawhi Leonard and we want him to
sound and act and look like a leader he
was almost better in that supporting
role they'd be all what a great story
Kawhi Leonard and he's one of the top
five players in the NBA two-way players
now you want him to be out in front
where he's quotable you interview him
they do profiles in ESPN The Magazine
and you're just not getting that from
Kawhi Leonard I don't understand for him
why he can't come out and be that guys
who would agree because he's hurt
himself so in my opinion he's really
hurt his value the way that he's
perceived smarter people and me have
said what is he doing I just I don't
understand it because he we already knew
he wasn't a great talker you know he
wasn't that Kobe or MJ that really
charismatic superstar but at 26 years
old that you know this guy should have
every ounce of media savvy and the
ability to relate he just for whatever
reason either doesn't want it or is
incapable of doing it and I think it has
hurt his value to a degree you had
another story where you talked to some
people around the NFL and there was one
quarterback where it feels like they
love his personality and I was surprised
that these executives are all in on
Baker Mayfield's personality how did
that come about because it almost feels
like that personality you're on the
fence you either love it or you don't
it's really surprising for me to dance I
think
the perception of Baker Mayfield
throughout his college career was great
player undersized isn't Johnny Manziel
is he going to be a lighting law
polarizing guy in your locker room what
I found is that people around the league
have said to me that they feel like it's
not
Keke's he's not Johnny Manziel a he's a
better player he's probably the most
accomplished winning quarterback when
you couple the statistics arguably in
the history of college football I mean
if you look at what he's done in the
last three years it's essentially
unparalleled but what off the field he's
been really good at which is relating
the teams showing them that you can
build around him you can trust him then
and that Baker Mayfield is actually very
likable he's been from what I've been
told pretty good on the board which
matters to these teams and I think he's
not Josh Rosen in that sense but he's
not somebody that like a Johnny Manziel
who obviously told you recently that
when he was drafted he was not all about
football that his Baker Mayfield this
dude's all about football and he's all
about winning and I think the record and
the results of that really speak to that
and this is lying season the next couple
of weeks because nobody's going to tell
you the truth on what's gonna happen
with the draft and it feels right
there's so much misinformation and
everything I've heard for the last five
five weeks is the Browns are taking John
Allen now you know they're we're
starting to hear a little bit about Sam
darn 'old again but it just feels like
and it's too quiet for me where I just
can't I'm not believing it I've learned
too too many times where I've been wrong
where I go yep it sounds like they're
settling in on this guy
what do you think happens how does this
all play out with these quarterbacks
yeah you talk about that misinformation
and smoke signals and you know trade
rumors the Browns are interesting
because they do have the 1n4 and you
could easily make the argument that they
should just take the best player on the
board say qualms Berkeley at one and
build from there because they need
talent but I do believe ultimately it
will be Sam Donald I think his his pro
style on is the fact that he was able to
make the protection calls the line of
scrimmage the 34 turnover
last couple years are a concern there's
no question about it but I think he's a
no-nonsense guy
I think he'll relate Cleveland obviously
is desperate for a quarterback I know
you talked about this there might not be
a better football city in the country
certainly in the top three or three to
five I mean they deserve it
and I do believe it is Sam Donnell
that's going to ultimately be the guy
Jordan great stuff thanks for joining us
we'll talk soon my pleasure thank you
Dan
that's a Jordan Schultz who covers the
NFL and NBA for Yahoo Sports insider and
analyst there for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]